Prof: Good morning,
let us begin.
Today we're going to move away
from the first dimension of
music that we've been looking
at,
which is duration,
or time, and begin to work with
the second,
which is pitch, and melody.
And here's an initial question
for you.
Think of the texture of music
and think of these strands of
high and low.
Where does melody sit in the
texture?
Is it high, middle or low?
Where is it?
If you think about it
conceptually,
try to figure out,
well, I got this board up here,
this tapestry,
or whatever,
where's my melody going to be
in the texture:
high,
middle or low?
Michael?
Student:  It would be
high.
Prof: Yeah, usually high.
Now, here's an interesting
question for you,
why is it usually high?
There's an acoustical reason
for this.
Why does the melody show up in
the high range?
Student:
>
Prof: I beg your pardon?
Student:  It's easier to
hear.
Prof: It's easier to
hear in a high range.
Why is it easier to hear in a
high range?
What about the acoustics here?
Once again, the laws of
acoustics.
Why is it easier to hear in a
high range?
I could play for you,
for example,
a little bit of Mozart.
It would sound like this.
>
You like that?
Sounds better up there,
doesn't it?
Why is that the case?
Yeah.
Student:  Maybe you can
put the frequency of the higher
pitches as high so you can
detect the sound quicker and
>.
Prof: That's it exactly.
In a melody,
we tend to have a lot of
rhythmic activity there.
It's got to have activity to
play itself out as melody.
But because the way sound waves
operate, we have these low sound
waves taking a very long time to
clear.
The higher frequencies take a
lot shorter time to clear.
They're short sound waves.
They clear very quickly.
So, we can hear a melody--we
can hear a melody more clearly
in this higher register and
therefore,
there is always the tendency to
have the bass play long,
low notes because those sounds
take a long time to clear and
melodies play faster notes
because those sounds clear
quickly and we can hear and
enjoy the melody.
All right, that's just an
opening thought about why
melodies show up in the top part
of the texture.
Let's talk about melody here
and let's talk about pitch.
We said before that in Western
music we have musical notation.
And musical notation is relied
on more in Western music than
any other musical civilization
around the world.
And in the West,
this whole idea of pitch
notation goes back to the ninth
century,
when the monks and nuns in
Benedictine abbeys in
Switzerland and France and
Germany and northern Italy
started doing this;
they started marking on
parchment or slate the general
course of a melody.
Eventually, what they did was
to separate these lines into
more discreet places,
or more discreet pitches.
Then around one thousand in
northern Italy,
an enterprising fellow named
Guido of Arezzo came along and
said, "Well,
you know what?
I can get this to show us how
far up we are supposed to go,
by placing it on some kind of
grid here,"
and this is this--
as I said before,
the beginning of the first
graph in the history of the
West.
This grid of horizontal lines
(and we will know that if we're
going from here to here),
it's got to be exactly this
frequency, or at least this
space.
So, initially they came up with
four lines and then eventually
five and even six,
and then they went back to five
by the fifteenth century.
What they also did around the
year one thousand was to
identify--to label--these
particular spots--spaces and
lines.
So they began to call this A
and this B and this C and this D
and this E, this F,
this G.
When they got up here,
they stopped.
Why did they stop?
Why didn't they keep right on
going with G,
H, I, J, K, L,
M, N, O, P?
Why don't we sing Ms and Os and
Ps today?
Why did they stop?
Any ideas?
>
Roger?
Student:
>
Prof: Yeah,
they had this thing--they hit
this thing called the octave.
And, of course,
there's this--another
acoustical phenomenon here we've
talked about before,
what's the relationship within
an octave?
The string is vibrating higher
when it's exactly twice what the
lower one is .
So, they heard this and they
heard this as essentially all
one sound.
So, if it's a duplication of
sound, let's duplicate the
letters.
But you can look at manuscripts
of the early eleventh century
and see people singing Ps and Ls
and Os and Ms and things like
that.
But eventually,
they began to uniformly adopt
this system of what's called
"octave duplication."
And every musical culture
around the world--
and I've talked with
ethnomusicologists about this
particular point--
every musical culture around
the world,
Chinese, Japanese,
Indonesian, Indian,
African whatever,
they all use this phenomenon of
octave duplication in their
music--
octave duplication in the music.
But how they divide up this
sonic space within the octave
can vary rather considerably.
Some Arabic music seems to have
as many as fourteen gradations
within the octave.
Now, we're going to listen to a
piece of music here from the
tradition of classical India and
I thought we might have a sitar
player in here.
Somebody--I got wind of the
fact we might have a classical
Indian musician in our class,
somebody that had studied the
sitar and might be able to come
in and play one for us.
But we don't have that,
so we're going to use something
on our CDs by the world famous
sitarist, Ravi Shankar.
Okay, you've probably heard of
him.
He's actually quite old now.
He must be--surely he's in his
eighties.
He was very famous when I was
in graduate school tons and tons
of years ago.
So--but he is the
venerable sitar player.
And here is the pattern,
the raga.
We'll call it a scale.
It's not really a scale but a
raga that he is using.
It's got only six notes within
the octave.
>
Prof: And the six notes
are-->
--that particular pattern.
Doesn't sound like any scale
we've ever heard of.
So, let's listen to Ravi
Shankar play a bit of a raga
using a six-note scale.
>
Okay, so that gives you a
flavor of that and you have
that, of course,
on your CD number six,
fifteen.
So that's a bit of sitar music.
Now, we're going to play
another six-note scale.
Let's go onto that one when
Lynda gets set.
And this, of course,
is sung by Nora Jones.
And, as you know from reading
the textbook,
why do I mention Nora Jones?
Or why do we play Nora Jones
right after Ravi Shankar?
Student:  It's his
daughter..
Prof: It's his
daughter.
Isn't that interesting?
Every Saturday morning I'm
going through Stop 'N Shop and
there's Nora Jones in the
background playing.
I'm going down the pasta aisle
or whatever, and I have the
daughter of Ravi Shankar over my
shoulder.
What a world, huh?
So, we're going to listen to
just a couple of seconds here of
a blues tune sung by Nora Jones.
>
Okay, so we'll just cut off
here.
But what she's working off of
here--we're not going to listen
to the whole thing--is this idea
of a blues scale.
>
And so on. How's that operate?
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
With this one,
sometimes major and sometimes
minor.
We'll come back to that part.
So, that's another six-note
scale but a different sort of
pattern, a different kind of
pattern.
It's a blues scale pattern.
It's kind of between the major
and minor that we'll talk about
a little bit later on.
So, two different forms of a
six-note pattern,
let's go to a five-note
pattern.
If you've ever visited parts of
Indonesia--
which I have not--and if you've
ever visited parts of China--
which I have not--I am told
that you will hear this kind of
music.
It's played by a traditional
Chinese instrument called the
erhu.
This I have seen around the
world many times and heard.
It's a two-stringed instrument
that produces a particularly
beautiful, vibrant tone.
So, we're going to listen to an
erhu playing.
I think this is track--if you
want to pursue it,
it's track--six-CD--track
sixteen.
Let's listen to an erhu play a
melody by a traditional Chinese
composer--
we call him in English
"Abbing"
and you can read about him
there in your textbook.
>
Okay, so let's see--let's pick
that up.
>
Five notes within the octave
just there.
So, it's a penta--what we call
a pentatonic scale.
And that's used in a lot of Far
East cultures--the pentatonic
scale, just a five-note scale
there.
Okay, so we have--there's a
whole idea of octave
duplication--sometimes six
notes, sometimes five notes.
We in the west have settled on
a seven-note scale.
Why did that happen?
Well, we have this idea of a
seven-note major and seven-note
minor.
Why seven notes?
Well, for the answer to that we
have to go back to ancient Greek
music theory,
and when you read about
this--it's really turgid stuff--
but believe it or not,
I teach a course on this at the
graduate level.
We have to read--poor Lynda has
to take this kind of
stuff--reading Aristoxenus and
things like this.
So, what we're dealing here
with is a situation where the
ancient Greeks were very much
into mathematics as a way of
explaining the world and
explaining music in particular .
And they thought these ratios
were primary.
So, they had the ratio of two
to one,
which gave them the octave,
and three to two,
which gave them the fifth,
and four to three,
which gave them the fourth.
They also, because the system
worked out better for their
purposes, then jumped to nine to
eight, which gave them the whole
tone.
So, they started out there and
let's say they were working down
here.
They filled in the octave up
above and then they filled in
the fifth and then they filled
in the fourth and then they came
down a whole step and then they
went up a fourth from that whole
step and then up a fourth from
that,
and they were filling in in
this fashion.
Interestingly enough--and you
ever wonder this?--sometimes
somebody will wander by a
keyboard and say,
"That's odd."
What's the great oddity about
the keyboard?
What's strange about this
keyboard?
It's very asymmetrical, right?
Marcus?
Student:  It's missing
>.
Prof: Yeah,
it's missing some notes in
here.
It's missing something in here,
and it's missing--well what
these are were the cracks.
After the Greeks laid out their
fifths and fourths and whole
steps, they had these little
leftovers.
They called them leimmas.
They had these little leftovers
in there and that's why we end
up with these small distances
between B and C
>
That's a big step.
That's a small step there.
So, the scale is actually not
equal.
A to B is one distance,
which is a large one,
and B to C is only half that
distance,
and that's because of the way
the Greeks laid this thing out
with their two to one ratios,
three to two ratios and so on.
But in any event,
we end up with this.
Now, the Greeks had a whole
series of patterns.
They called them mixolydian,
and hypomixolydian and phrygian
and hypophrygian and stuff like
this.
A lot of different patterns.
But in the course of history,
we settled beginning in the
sixteenth and seventeenth
century,
down into just two patterns:
what we call the major pattern
and the minor pattern.
So, let's talk about that just
for a moment.
And before we do it,
I should add one other thing:
how, then, do we get these
other notes up here,
we get these other notes up
here?
Well, what we now call the
black notes--
although historically keyboards
could be either way--
you could have these added
notes black or white and then
these underneath would be black.
So we filled these out.
In the fourteenth century,
all of this got filled in.
These between B and C and E and
F didn't get filled in because
they were already just the
smallest amount that they wanted
to deal with,
just half steps.
So, we end up here within an
octave--
we end up with twelve equal
pitches,
but we still use this term a
'seven-note scale' because we
have seven notes within the
scale of the major scale and
seven notes within the scale of
the minor scale.
All right, so let's talk about
major and minor now.
And we've put those patterns up
here.
This is given for you in your
textbook.
This is something of a review.
Let's start with a major scale
on a C.
So, here is the symbol for C
and the staff here is where C
would be located on the
keyboard.
We're going to start here and
we have this pattern of the
major that goes whole,
whole, half,
whole, whole,
whole, half step.
So, we start on C and then we
go up to D--a whole step.
I'm going to write that in here.
That's good,
then we go D up to E;
that's another whole step.
Now, I have a half step.
I got to go up just a half step
there, I'm on E.
But it's just--F is just a half
step away, so that's good.
I don't need to do anything
more than that.
Now, I'm on F here.
Well, I need a whole step.
There's my one.
I need a whole step.
I got to go up to G and then
another whole step up to A and
then another whole step up to B.
And the last one in the major
pattern is a half step from B to
C.
There we are, and that's good.
So, we've got our major scale.
Let's talk a little bit about
the minor scale.
Now, it's got a different
pattern.
It's got a different pattern.
They like melodies to go
this way.
Let's start on the same pitch,
C.
Let's go up a whole step.
What's a whole step above C?
Up--just D.
Now, we need,
according to our pattern,
to go up just a half step.
What's a half step above D?
Well, then we have to think
about it.
We've got to get into these
black notes, which can be called
sharps or flats.
They're called sharps if
they're up above the note in
question.
This would be some kind of D
sharp.
They're called flats if they're
down below.
So, flats are below,
sharps take you up a half step.
So, we went C to D.
We need this pitch, here.
What are we going to call it?
Student:
>
Prof: Or,
we are going to call it D
sharp?
Well, we should call it E- flat.
We should call it E-flat and
put it up on the E line because
there's kind of rule here that
you have to use up each letter
name in turn,
each letter name in turn.
We can't go C, D, D-sharp, F.
We got to go C,
D, some kind of E,
F.
So, you've got to go up the
alphabet here.
All right, so there we are,
but is this,
from D to E,
a half step?
We need a half step here.
What we've written is a whole
step, so we've got to indicate
that this is just a half step
away in that fashion,
D to E-flat.
Now, what do we do above E flat?
Well, a whole step
here--there's one half,
there's another half,
would take us to F,
whole step above F,
would take us to G.
What am I going to write here?
From G I need a half step.
Here is--it doesn't--here's the
pattern up here.
We'll focus on this one.
I need a half step above G.
What's a half step above G?
Student:
>
Prof: A-flat.
Okay, I need,
now, a whole step above A-flat.
Hmm, nice and loud please,
Edward?
Student:
>
Prof: B-flat, okay.
And then at the end of the
process I have another whole
step from B-flat back to C,
and that gets me back to my
octave in that fashion.
Okay, well, I think that's
straightforward enough.
If you're unsure about that,
check out, of course,
chapter three in the textbook,
where these issues are
addressed.
Okay, we've been talking about
scales, these ideas of major and
minor scales.
We said there are seven notes
in each of these two scales,
twelve pitches all together
within the octave.
But within the scale,
all notes are not the same.
There's one note that's the
primary note,
right?
What's the primary note called,
the note around which all of
the others--all the others
gravitate?
Student:
>
Prof: Tonic note, okay?
Then there's one other that we
have to know about,
it's called the leading tone.
And what it does is pull into
the tonic.
Let's say we're in the key of C
here.
The leading tone is always the
seventh degree.
It's always a half step--always
a half step--seventh degree,
right below,
right below the tonic.
You might say,
"Wait a minute,
I thought the tonic was down
here."
Well, you got one,
two, three, four,
five, six, seven and eight.
Eight is a duplication of one.
Eight and one are the tonic.
So, seven pulls up into eight.
It pulls up into eight--the
tonic.
<<plays piano and
sings>>
That's the leading tone.
Where's it want to go?
Student:
>
<<sings while playing
piano>>
Prof: You can hear it
pulling in there.
Opera singers love this.
They love to kind of luxuriate
in the opportunity to show off
their voice on a leading tone,
build up expectation,
make you wait even more for
that tonic.
Let's listen to Luciano
Pavarotti sing a leading tone,
and as by coincidence,
it happens to be the one-year
anniversary of Pavarotti's death
this week.
So, here's Luciano Pavarotti
singing a leading tone.
The tempo here is very slow and
he slows it down even more and
then it just sits out there,
this huge wonderful voice that
he had,
on the leading tone.
<<Pavarotti
singing>>
Prof: Okay,
and you can hear him sort of--
he didn't
go-->
He went-- >
You could hear him slide that
leading tone up into the tonic
in that case.
Okay, so we've got across the
idea of tonics and leading
tones.
Did we do tonics?
Do we know what a tonic is?
>
Sing it.
So, given the set-up,
you kind of feel what you're
missing, you know,
what this home pitch is--the
pitch to which you are
gravitating.
Most of our popular music,
folk songs and things like
that, are written in duple meter
and in a major key.
Occasionally,
you get things written in
triple meter and in a minor
key--minor key.
>
That's Gershwin:
Porgy and Bess,
in minor.
Folk song--<<plays
piano>>
Old Civil War song.
And so on it goes.
Occasionally,
you do run into pop pieces,
folk songs, in minor,
but most of them are in
major--probably about eighty
percent in major.
Same thing in the classical
realm.
Lynda, what would you say,
what percentage of classical
pieces are written in minor
keys?
Student:  Very small.
Prof: Well,
give us a number,
take a--
Student:  Five percent.
Prof: Only five?
Student:  It's classical?
Prof: Classical,
maybe a little more than that,
but not all that many.
Here's-- Student:
>
Prof: I don't know,
we should do a survey sometime.
Go through the literature,
see what--but mostly,
for the most part,
it shows minor--major.
Occasionally, minor is chosen.
Here's a good example of a
minor from the second movement
of Beethoven's Third Symphony.
>.
But from Mozart,
major--difference between major
and minor.
>
Lovely major.
So, we're used to making
associations with major and
minor.
Major: happy,
bright, optimistic,
a day like today.
Minor: somber.
>
Why is that the case?
Is there anything in the
physics of this music?
No, not really.
There's nothing in the laws of
acoustics here that cause that
to be the case.
If you look back over it,
there was no major or minor in
western music up until about
sixteenth century,
and then people started writing
these things called madrigals,
that were tied to texts.
And they got in this habit of,
every time they had a bright,
happy text, they'd set this in
one kind of mode or key--
a major mode--and every time
they had a sad one,
they'd set it in minor.
We got used to hearing it that
way,
so it's kind of--every time,
you know,
Schumann wants to write about
the merry farmer--
>
But every time Chopin wants to
write a funeral
march--<<plays
piano>>.
And there's a tendency
also--minor: low,
major: high kind of thing.
So, we get used to this.
And this point-- that it is
culture rather than acoustics--
was brought home to me once in
a discussion with a student here
at Yale who said to me,
"Yeah, but over there at
the Slifka Center,
we Jews have lots of happy
melodies and they are all in
minor--
what you would call minor."
And so I thought about that,
"Yeah, that's probably
true."
Even the-- <<plays
piano>>
Isn't that the Israeli national
anthem?
I think so.
Is that right? What is that?
What? Yes or no?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Okay,
but it may be--how many
national anthems around the
world do we have in minor keys?
And what does this say about
the tradition of Jewish music?
Is it really Western or is it
Eastern European or even with
some Asian influences?
Interesting issues--issues that
can be brought home.
This kind of ambiguity
sometimes you encounter in
klezmer music.
What's klezmer music?
Traditional Jewish folk music,
a lot of it coming out of
Eastern Europe.
So, we're going to listen to a
kind of souped up,
or rocked up,
version of some klezmer music
here,
and they have a strong bass,
electric bass underneath.
And we're going to listen
to-->
A minor melody with a leading
tone thrown in that gives it
this kind of exotic feel and
then it will switch to major.
So, let's listen to this bit of
klezmer music go back and forth
between minor and major.
>
Okay, so that's the intro.
Now, we're going to go onto the
shift to major here,
another little clip.
>
So, there it's in major.
Let's listen a little bit more.
It's going to go back to minor
and then I think shift back to
major.
We'll be able to hear the shift.
Turn it down just a little bit,
Lynda, please.
>
Major or minor?
Raise your left hand if you
think it's minor.
What about this: major or minor?
Right hand if it's major,
left if it's minor.
This is major.
>
Okay, that's a little bit of
this ambiguity between major and
minor in a piece of traditional
Jewish music.
Let's see, we've talked
about--let's talk about hearing,
how we hear these melodies.
The reason that we hear these
as distinctly different,
I think, happens rather early
on in the scale.
Let's think about this for a
minute.
We've got this scale up here.
>
If you go over to this scale.
Does that sound dark?
I don't know.
Five hundred years ago,
that wouldn't have sounded
dark.
Now, that sounds dark to us,
ominous.
>
But that darkness occurs very
early in the scale.
As you can see there,
it's the third note.
We'll be talking about the fact
that this is an interval of a
third;
it spans three letter names a
little bit later on.
So, that minor third can show
up very early in the scale.
That's a critical moment in any
scale, determining how we're
going to feel about it.
We can just play with that
particular interval to change
entirely the way we feel about
particular melodies.
Here is a Christian song.
I guess it's--<<plays
piano>>
"Joy to the world,
the Lord has come,"
don't we sing it as a Christmas
carol, or some can sing it as a
Christmas carol?
>
Not much joy there.
You like that one?
How about-- <<plays
piano>>
Or my favorite
is-->
You know, you can turn this
whole thing into a Jewish bar
mitzvah or something like that.
You were singing with the Coen
Brothers down somewhere in,
you know, in Appalachia.
What was the wonderful movie
that had the Coen Brothers and
all that great American folk
music in it?
You Are My Sunshine,
Brother, Where Art Thou?
Wasn't that what it was
called?
Brother, Where Art Thou?
Yeah.
So, just that little turn of a
switch there.
You can do some great things
with changing the mode.
So, we've got scales that are
in the major mode;
we've got scales in the minor
mode.
We also have scales in the
chromatic mode and that's when
we don't have just seven pitches
within the scale.
We're going to use all
of the pitches,
all twelve here.
Chroma is the Greek word
for color.
So, this is a more colorful
scale.
What does it do for us?
>
Well, that's a chromatic scale.
We had an example of that the
other day working with the
Mozart--where was that?
In the Requiem.
Oh phooey.
Yeah, remember we had--he was
coming up a minor scale.
>
And then he,
at the top of it--<<plays
scale>>
--switched over into a
chromatic scale.
Here's the score.<<plays
piano>>
Minor.<<plays
Now chromatic.
>
What does this do to us?
Why did he do that?
Well, chromaticism adds tension
to music and especially
chromaticism that's pulling up.
Scales that go up add tension.
Music goes up generally in
tension--
but if you can double that,
combine that with chromatic
music,
then you've got a sort of super
whammy of tension,
and that's what he's doing
there--trying to build tension
as the Just rise from the graves
at that particular point.
Entire compositions are rarely
written in the chromatic scale.
Yeah, it's kind of a color that
you throw in from time to time
for special effect.
So, we've got the major/minor
scales;
we've got the chromatic scales.
We also have what we call
conjunct melodies.
>
Melodies that are just running
up and down a scale--
neighboring tones.
>
Those are two Christmas carols
that are very conjunct in
nature.
A good example--we used it a
moment ago--of a disjunct melody
is-->
Can we all sing that?
Here we go.
Ready, sing,
"Take me out to the
ballgame.
Take me out to the park,
etc…"
It's amazing that that melody
has become as popular as it has
given the fact that it's really
hard to sing.
It's a very disjunct melody.
It's got all these odd leaps to
it.
>
Sounds like Schoenberg almost.
It's sort of off the map here
in terms of disjunctness.
But nonetheless,
we have been able to absorb all
of that.
So, melodies can be conjunct or
disjunct.
And possibly the most conjunct
of all melodies in the history
of music was the melody that we
looked at very briefly in the
first gathering,
and that is Beethoven's famous
Ode to Joy.
Now, Ludwig van Beethoven was
in his fifties when he was
working on his last symphony--
what would prove to be his last
symphony--
his Ninth Symphony,
and he'd been tinkering with
this particular melody all the
way back to probably 1803,
so it's about twenty years or
so.
Ninth Symphony is 1823-1824.
As early as 1803,
we know he's working
on-->
Trying to get this to work just
right.
And eventually,
over this twenty-year period he
did get it to work just right.
Let me swing this board around.
Here's the famous melody.
I've put it in the key--what's
called the bass clef here--and
it's in a major key.
We don't need to know what the
particular notes are,
but let's look at this just for
a moment because it works well
as a prototype of melody.
It does something that a lot of
melodies do.
First of all,
as you can see by the
trajectory here,
it's very conjunct,
right, all neighboring notes
here.
If you look at the German of
the text, it has to do with
>
. The millions be
embraced.
And this, I believe,
is the sort of national anthem
for the United Nations.
So, this has to be something
that we can all sing.
And if you have conjunct
motion, that makes it easier.
It's also very symmetrical.
As you can see,
it's nothing but a pattern of
four bars plus four bars plus
four bars plus four bars.
And, as we said before,
music has a syntax so that
these phrases have to be in
a--arranged in a particular way
that makes sense.
So, we start out here with an
opening phrase.
>
Is that the tonic?
Student:  No.
Prof: Can anybody sing
the tonic?
Student:
>
Prof: Yeah,
yeah-- >
Prof: The tonic is
actually over here.
It's a little bit lower than
that.
That was a really hard question.
I'm amazed that anybody got it.
Good for you.
So, what happens here is this
opening phrase,
that we'll call A--musicians
like to label stuff just with
alphabetical labels to keep it
simple.
We'll call this phrase A.
It sort of opens things up,
and we refer to this as the
antecedent phrase.
The next phrase,
B-->
is very similar,
but here it takes the
deviation--<&
lt;sings>>
And gets it back--gets us back
to the tonic.
Now, we could walk out the door
at that point,
right?
>
We're feeling tonally stable
there.
We've got it all together for
the rest of the day.
However, it would be a pretty
short melody.
So, what he then does is write
an extension.
We'll call this C.
>
Very interesting.
Put an asterisk by this.
Beethoven, in a way,
saved this melody.
He rescued this melody,
which was in danger of becoming
excessively four-square,
by doing what?
If I had been writing
it-->
What did Beethoven do here?
We talked about it last time,
a rhythmic device.
Syncopation.
He brings his opening note,
that F-sharp,
in a beat early.
This should,
you would think,
be a half note and this would
start on the downbeat,
over here.
But he brings,
in effect, the sound of the
downbeat in a beat early,
gives it a little bit of pep
there at that particular point.
And then what is this here?
>
Well, of course it's a
replication of B.
We've got to end on the tonic.
All pieces, classical or pop,
one way or the other,
end on the tonic.
Okay, so let's have us,
now--let me put a fermata over
this.
Let's all sing this.
I think it--we don't have to
read the notes.
You don't have to sing any
texts;
we're just going to sing
"la."
I'll conduct in four,
so sit back.
>
Everybody vocally prepared here?
Here we go.
I'll give you one,
two, ready, sing.
>
Louder, louder.
Good.
>
We'll put a big ritard
on it there.
So, we wanted to bang that
syncopation and then,
of course, there's no sound on
the downbeat over here to make
the syncopation work.
So, that's the melody.
Seems very simple,
but took Beethoven a long time
to iron all this out and make
this perfect melody,
the prototypical melody in a
way.
And then in the early eighteen
twenties, he decided to
incorporate this as the main
theme of the last movement,
the finale of his last
symphony.
So, this is some of the last
music that Beethoven wrote in
the setting that we're about to
listen to.
So, let's listen,
we're not going to--I think
Lynda has it set here.
We're going to hear the
beginning of this and he
presents this as a series of
variations.
So here is the first
presentation of our melody.
>
Nice and loud.
Student:
>
Prof: That's okay.
Prof: And then he
repeats C and B.
>
Okay, now let's pause it there.
Let's pause it right there.
Now, we're going to go on to
the second presentation of the
theme, and I have three
questions for you as we do so.
Where has the theme--the
melody--gone here?
Is this a motive or a theme,
by the way?
Student:
>
Prof: Theme,
it's not a motive.
It's way too long.
It's a good example of a theme.
It's way too long for a motive.
Motive would only go about
four, five, six notes.
So, we have this beautiful
theme here and as we listen to
this next presentation,
where has the theme,
or melody, gone?
What instruments are playing it
now?
What is the texture like?
How many lines can you hear in
this texture?
How many strands of music do
you hear--can you pick up?
And thirdly,
what is this texture called?
Last time we said we had three
kinds of texture in music which
are: monophonic,
homophonic and polyphonic.
Which is this particular
texture?
Okay, here we go.
>
So, what do you think?
How many lines--first of all,
where has the melody gone--the
theme?
Student:
>
Prof: It's gone up a
little bit and it's being played
by what instruments?
Yeah, strings,
violins, violins,
but not the top part of the
violin family,
kind of second violin,
middle range of the strings
here.
How many parts do you hear in
it?
How many separate musical lines
there?
Marcus?
Student:  Three..
Prof: Three.
Tell us about those three.
We've just talked about one of
them--the melody and the violins
up above.
Can you tell us about some of
the others?
Student:
>
Prof: Okay,
they're doing like a
counterpoint,
right.
They're doing-- yeah, okay.
It's too easy. I'm sorry.
I had to go for that.
They are playing a contrapuntal
line.
But you're absolutely right,
that's the key point and that
then answers,
Marcus, what's the texture.
If you've got a--Marcus, please?
Student:  Polyphonic..
Prof: Yeah,
polyphonic.
So, this is polyphony here.
What was the third voice?
If we had melody up above in
kind of a counterpoint,
as Marcus says,
there, in the middle,
what was the--we had one other
part, and what was that?
Well, let's listen a little
more.
We've identified the melody.
Let's just see if we can pick
up what the missing third part
here.
It's a bassoon playing the
contrapuntal line.
>
Prof: So,
what is the third part there?
The bass, yeah.
Usually, you're going to have a
melody and you're going to have
a bass, so the bass is doing
stuff--<<plays
piano>>
--underneath there.
So, there's the melody up
above, this bassoon playing the
counterpoint,
kind of in the middle,
and then the bass playing these
notes quietly underneath.
It's a little bit hard to hear.
I think we have time.
Let's just continue right from
there a little bit more.
>
Can you hear the bass, now?
There's the bassoon,
counterpoint.
>
Okay, and let's listen to just
a little--we're going to pause
it there.
Now, let's listen to,
must be, what,
the third presentation,
here, of the theme.
Where's the theme now?
Now, how many parts are there
in the texture?
>
What about that?
Well, it's a little bit hard to
tell exactly,
isn't it?
It's hard to tell.
What could you say for sure
about it?
You've got a melody.
Where's it going now?
It's going up.
It's all now in the first
violins.
What else is in there?
Student:
>
Prof: A bass,
yeah, we got a bass.
And now we--what else?
Some other stuff in the middle,
all right?
And that's--that may be about
as much as we can do with that.
I mean, really, myself included.
I could sort of sit there and
try to track the lines,
but I'd have to repeat it.
So, I think if we said we've
got melody, we've got theme,
we've got bass,
we've got a bunch of other
stuff in the middle,
that's just fine and dandy.
But the idea that they're all
kind of independent,
points out once again that they
are playing polyphonic texture.
Let's listen to the end of the
polyphonic texture,
then Beethoven,
and we'll stop with this.
Beethoven was like a military
general, interesting the way he
operated, always setting up
these battles.
And indeed, he wrote something
called a Battle Symphony,
and you can just see him,
how he's kind of marshalling
particular forces to do
particular things at particular
times.
So, held back here the heavy
artillery.
The heavy artillery in the
orchestra is what?
The brass and sometimes
percussion.
So, it's the brass he's going
to bring in at this point.
So, we'll listen to the end of
the third presentation of this
with the contrapuntal idea
dominated by strings,
melody, bass,
other stuff in the middle and
then he will bring in the brass
for the final statement of this.
And I think our time is about
up, so we'll listen to this and
you can go out as we hear the
fourth statement of this.
>